una larga batalla legislativa que
termina en victoria el congreso chileno
aprobó por una amplia mayoría reducir de
45 a 40 horas la jornada laboral semanal
dejando al país con la semana de trabajo
más corta de América Latina junto a
Ecuador queremos manifestar una gran
alegría porque hoy día ha quedado
demostrado que aunque algunos pensaran
que era imposible avanzar en una mejor
calidad de vida para las y los
trabajadores de nuestro país sí se puede
la propuesta fue realizada en 2017 y
tuvo varios tropiezos pero fue retomada
como una promesa de campaña por el ahora
presidente Gabriel Boris y finalmente
este 11 de abril fue aprobada con 127
votos a favor 14 en contra y tres
abstenciones en la cámara de diputados
así chile y Ecuador siguen las
recomendaciones de la organización
Internacional del trabajo por su parte
países como Brasil Honduras República
Dominicana y El Salvador trabajan entre
41 y 45 horas mientras que otros como
México Colombia y Argentina trabajan
entre 46 y 48 horas a la semana la nueva
ley chilena cuenta con gran apoyo
popular Y tuvo el visto bueno de
sindicatos y empresarios está bien
porque la gente tiene tiempo para la
familia y también con Los sueldos que
hay puede ser que puedan tener algún
pololito algún pitito entonces no es
malo usted nos ha permitido esta jornada
laboral mucho más reducida poder
estudiar muchos casos poder mantener
nuestros propios emprendimientos
paralelo al trabajo donde estamos y
generar otro tipo de actividades o
también están más tiempo con la familia
el cambio será aplicado progresivamente
la semana laboral será reducida a 44
horas en un año luego a 42 en el tercer
año de aplicación y finalmente a 40
horas en un plazo de cinco años El
presidente borish podría promulgar la
ley el primero de mayo coincidiendo con
el Día Internacional del trabajo